going back to the whole celebrity
machine what do you want people to take
away
once they see day out of days about the
main character about her struggle what
do you what do you want them to see
um i don't know i don't really
i wouldn't dictate that i think a story
is a story and everybody that's what's
great about reading a book or seeing a
piece of art or watching a movie or
seeing a photograph
is everybody finds their own relation to
it so
i would never tell anybody what to think
about it in fact i'd rather you tell me
what you thought about it
and how it would relate to you i know
how it relates to me
and i know how the story relates to me i
know how the story relates to alexia
and i feel that if we put as much truth
into the story and as much 100 percent
and
try to not give a false note then
everybody is going to have
you know their own opinion about it take
away whether they hated it or loved it
or you know whatever and i think that
to me that subjectiveness is so exciting
because you
are so specific about how what you want
to say and what you want to say and then
i mean as a writer you know and then you
give it to the actors and then the
actors say
oh what about this and you're like oh my
god that's amazing because i never
thought of that because i'm that close
to it
and then they bring something you have
to allow everybody to bring
stuff to the to the to the film
because that's how the collective
consciousness of the film gets born you
know
so whether they hated it and want to
throw you know cabbages at the screen
to me that's a reaction and i say you
know
go for it you know i just want people to
see the movie and i want to make the
movie and i want it to feel
good you know and your main character
does she have a love interest
i am so excited that this well she has a
love interest it's just that that in
that person isn't interested in her he
just doesn't know it yeah no she doesn't
this movie isn't centered around
like a man validating who you are which
i think is really interesting
i you know i mean i'm definitely into
like love stories
and finding yourself and being able to
find love but i already explored that
issue and i think this
is more about you know i i don't know
when you're in school and
the english teacher tells you like there
are five stories there's man versus
nature
there's man versus man there's man
versus himself and
this is a real man versus himself movie
about
somebody who had a moment
got lost for whatever reason we all do
at certain times lost her way and is
struggling to find their way back but
not the way back that's offered but the
way back that's truly
your way back what's going to help you
continue in your life and make you have
a happy life
so is it about also being seen
in the world when she feels invisible
yes i mean i think actors definitely
i mean people who want to be actors want
to be seen let's not be you know
coy about it you know i think
but i i mean i must want to be seen in a
way too by by writing and giving certain
parts of myself that are not necessarily
portrayed by me on screen but
you know through and i think
you know i think there's nothing wrong
with being seen or being want
to be seen it's just the extremity of it
now is so shocking you know
there's nothing left to there's no
mystery
left in the world and i think that you
know i come from a generation
before this new generation who i mean
who all know that there's only facetime
and texting and things that you know
never looking for like running home to
check their machine to see if there's a
message from the boy they love or
whatever you know i mean
there's a certain romance that we had
that before that was about
discovery and now discovery is every
second you know and so
it's interesting to find and i mean for
me to find an actress who's not so well
known you don't know her whole history
when you go
when you're watching her on screen which
i think is really interesting
and just to sit back and follow a real
story of someone's
ups and downs is you know
it's important i think it's important
i'm not saying my movie's important but
i'm saying it's important to hear human
stories and be able to relate to them
in this time where there's this kind of
mechanical
you know accoutrement to everything
everyone has a selfie on online
somewhere yeah i don't even know what
all these
they're always saying like lfmo or
something like that i don't know what
any of those things mean
and that's when i started to feel really
old
you